Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速告诉大家一件正在发生的令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我和我的商业导师Lisa Johnson共同发起的“Race to Recurring Revenue”挑战。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是准心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有由Lisa本人直接提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这成为你的指南。我是Marianne Trent博士，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客。
I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I am a qualified clinical psychologist. So, the first week of interviews for the clinical doctorate have happened which means that from this week onwards we might well be expecting we are expecting the first people to get their notifications about whether they're being offered places whether they're being offered reserve places or whether they are being told thank you but not yet and you know a whole array of feelings can be experienced as a result of that most definitely if it is a no, thank you, not yet, then some of those feelings you're experiencing might be complicated, painful and jagged. And yeah, as humans, it's not only ourselves that can find it unsettling when dealing with those painful, complicated feelings, but also those around us as well, either because it makes them feel uncomfortable or
我是Marianne Trent博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。临床博士课程的第一周面试已经结束，这意味着从本周开始，我们很可能会期待第一批申请者收到关于他们是否被录取、是否被列入候补名单，或者是否被告知“谢谢，但目前还不行”的通知。毫无疑问，这会导致各种各样的情绪。如果结果是“谢谢，但目前还不行”，那么你所经历的一些情绪可能会变得复杂、痛苦且尖锐。是的，作为人类，当面对这些痛苦、复杂的情绪时，不仅我们自己会感到不安，周围的人也会感到不安，要么是因为这让他们感到不舒服，
because it just stresses them to see you experience them and we can feel disappointment about all sorts of things like big and small you know on a very small scale I feel a bit disappointed that I worked quite hard on my hair this morning it was beautifully curly and then our lovely spring weather in the UK means that I've been caught in a rainstorm caught in squally winds and it's just you know it's not how I planned for this to go it's not how I imagined it all to work out and that is a very small scale problem you know it's a nicer problem to have isn't it but on a larger scale disappointment can feel really really difficult you know um and sometimes people will say to us especially for job stuff especially if you've had an interview for something or if you've even been turned down for an interview for something sometimes Sometimes people will say, well, you can't really be upset
要么是因为看到你经历这些让他们感到压力。我们可能会对各种各样的事情感到失望，无论大小。比如，在很小的层面上，我对自己今天早上精心打理的头发感到有点失望，它本来卷得很漂亮，但英国可爱的春季天气让我被困在暴雨和阵风中，这完全不是我计划中的样子，也不是我预想的结果。这是一个很小的问题，对吧？但从更大的层面来看，失望的感觉真的非常非常困难。有时人们会告诉我们，特别是对于工作相关的事情，如果你面试了某份工作，甚至连面试机会都被拒绝了，有时人们会说，你其实没必要难过，
because you never had it. You know, it was never yours. To that I say, bunkum. To that I say, codswallop. To that I say, well, utter rubbish. Because with our fantastically tricky human brains, we begin to imagine the things that we're going for coming to fruition. We begin to plan the moves. We begin to plan, you know, how that's going to feel, how exciting it's going to be, you know, and you're only applying for these things because you really want them, you know, or sometimes you apply for things you don't really want. And then you get offered it and you're like, oh, that's made me realize I didn't want that. Just kind of did it speculatively. But often, and most of the time when we apply for things, it's because we really want it. And I think the thing with psychology is, is that you're often seeing people who are celebrating the thing that you might be commiserating.
因为你从来没有得到过它。你知道，它从来都不属于你。对此我说，胡说八道。对此我说，一派胡言。对此我说，简直是废话。因为我们那极其复杂的人类大脑，会开始想象我们追求的事情即将实现。我们开始规划未来的行动。我们开始规划，你知道，那会是什么感觉，那会是多么令人兴奋。你申请这些东西只是因为你真的很想要它们，或者有时你申请了一些你并不是真的想要的东西，然后当你被录取时，你会想：“哦，这让我意识到我其实并不想要这个。”只是抱着试试看的心态。但通常情况下，大多数时候我们申请某样东西是因为我们真的很想要它。我认为心理学的问题在于，你经常看到别人在庆祝你可能正在哀悼的事情。
You know, for your average job interview, you're not having to actually find out ever who got the role. Whereas if it's a specific course that you've applied for and you've been told, no, thank you, not yet, then you might well on LinkedIn or Instagram or Twitter, see someone celebrating their win about getting on that course. And that would have potentially been your future cohort mate, you know. And it's really difficult because then our comparisonitis creeps in as well. And I just want to send you some love, really. And you might even feel disappointment if you get offered one place but not one of your
你知道，对于普通的工作面试，你永远不必知道是谁得到了这个职位。然而，如果你申请的是特定的课程，并且被告知“谢谢，但目前还不行”，那么你很可能在LinkedIn、Instagram或Twitter上看到别人在庆祝他们被该课程录取。那本可能是你未来的同学。这真的很困难，因为那时我们的“比较心理”也会随之而来。我真的只想给你一些关爱。如果你被录取了，但不是你最喜欢的学校，你甚至会感到失望，
favorite places and then you're thinking well this is going to be a bit tricky in terms of making this work for my family for my personal circumstances but I feel like I need to say yes to this because I'm so lucky or you know so many other people want this but actually you did want course A more than you wanted course B and then likely your life will follow the path of course B but not always if you recognize that that's not for you you can still say no you know it might feel like a cardinal sin to say no to a funded doctoral place, but you still get to choose, you know, you still get to have a life that feels vibrant and full and worth living and like a bit of you, you know. It's very difficult, it's very difficult. So yeah, just wanted to let you know my heart is
然后你会想，这在平衡家庭和个人情况方面会有点棘手，但我感觉我需要答应，因为我很幸运，或者你知道，还有很多人想要这个机会。但实际上，你确实比课程B更想要课程A，而你的生活很可能会沿着课程B的路径发展，但也不总是这样。如果你意识到那不适合你，你仍然可以拒绝。你知道，拒绝一个有资助的博士名额可能感觉像犯了弥天大罪，但你仍然可以选择，你仍然可以拥有一个感觉充满活力、充实、值得生活且属于你自己的生活。这非常困难，真的非常困难。所以，我只是想让你知道，我的心
going out to you right now, whatever you're feeling're feeling and of course if you have got a doctorate place and it is for a course that feels like a bit of you and going to fit into your life either because you're going to move your life to it or because you're already within appropriate safe traveling distances of it or you're just going to make it fit you know you're going to do some airbnb um you know three nights a week and you're thrilled then i'm so thrilled for you as well it's okay to celebrate as well even though others may not have been in the same fortuitous position as you you're allowed to be super super proud so yeah if someone is saying well you can't be upset because you never had it, then you can say, well, I can be upset because I am upset because I'm a human. So are you going to sit with me as I'm upset? Are you going to, you know, or are you going to go away and I'll be upset by myself?
此刻与你同在，无论你有什么样的感受。当然，如果你获得了博士名额，而且这门课程感觉很适合你，并且能融入你的生活——无论是你要搬过去住，还是你已经在合适的安全通勤距离内，或者你只是打算让它适应你的生活（比如每周住三晚Airbnb），并且你感到非常激动，那么我也为你感到非常激动。庆祝一下也是可以的，即使其他人可能没有像你这样幸运。你有权感到超级超级自豪。所以，如果有人说“你没必要难过，因为你从来没得到过它”，那么你可以说：“我可以难过，因为我确实很难过，因为我是个人。那么，在我难过的时候，你愿意陪着我吗？还是说你要走开，让我一个人难过？”
You've got choices because I'm feeling upset. You don't need to chiv me along. You don't need to distract me. You don't really need to cheer me up this is disappointment and I will move through it but right now I'm sitting with it because I'm a human and that's what we do so I'm really hoping that all of you get the news that you want but obviously more of the personal stories for people that I've been involved with during this application season are people in my aspiring psychologist membership I just want to take a moment to read you a little review about a session that someone attended recently. So this says, so the question was, did this session better prepare you for your journey as an aspiring psychologist? And the answer
你有选择权，因为我感到很难过。你不需要催促我，不需要分散我的注意力，也不需要强行让我振作起来。这就是失望，我会走出来的，但现在我正沉浸在其中，因为我是个人，这就是我们人类会做的事。所以我真的希望你们所有人都能得到你们想要的消息。当然，在这次申请季中，我所接触到的人中，更多个人故事来自我的“有抱负的心理学家”会员。我想花点时间读一下某人最近参加的一次会议的评价。问题是：这次会议是否让你为作为一名有抱负的心理学家的旅程做好了更好的准备？答案是：
was definitely. I find the membership so helpful and it gives me more confidence that I can speak and formulate an answer on the spot. So if that feels like something that you have struggled with in the past, really, you know, getting everything you need to do to fully enrich your answers, to be able to get the depth of answers that you might well need for psychology interviews, then do please consider coming on board to the Aspiring Psychologist Members pounds a month but there's no minimum term so you can leave if you decide it's not for you and if research is a tricky area for you then don't worry we've got that covered too so when asked about our research about our research, whether it had been useful. Somebody had said, it was literally everything I could ask for when prepping for the research aspects of the interview. What is not to like? So yeah, if you feel like that would be useful, those two examples would be useful for you then come on board the water is lovely
绝对是。我发现会员服务非常有帮助，它让我更有信心在现场发言并组织答案。所以，如果这听起来像是你过去一直在挣扎的事情，真的，你知道，为了充分丰富你的答案，为了能够达到心理学面试可能需要的深度，请务必考虑加入“有抱负的心理学家”会员。每月只需几英镑，但没有最低期限，所以如果你觉得不适合你，随时可以离开。如果研究对你来说是一个棘手的领域，别担心，我们也涵盖了这一点。当被问及我们的研究是否有用时，有人说：“这简直是我在准备面试的研究方面所能要求的一切。还有什么不满意的呢？”所以，如果你觉得这些例子对你有用，那就加入我们吧，水温很舒适。
but I do still of course I'm passionate about offering free support for you whatever stage you're at in your journey so these podcasts will remain and of course we've got the compassionate Q&A that you can come along to live so we had Monday the 13th of March, and that was the one that never actually happened. It did in fact happen on Tuesday the 13th of March, and you can catch that on my YouTube channel. If you're watching on YouTube, please do subscribe. If you're not watching on YouTube,
但我当然仍然热衷于为你提供免费支持，无论你处于旅程的哪个阶段。所以这些播客会保留下来，当然我们还有你可以现场参加的“同情问答”环节。我们原定于3月13日星期一举行，但那次实际上没办成。它实际上是在3月13日星期二举行的，你可以在我的YouTube频道上观看回放。如果你正在YouTube上观看，请务必订阅。如果你没有在YouTube上观看，
take a moment to just scroll to YouTube as you listen and subscribe to Dr. Marianne Trent. You can watch the replay there, but you can also come along for the live sessions via my socials, Dr. Marianne Trent. The next one is on Monday, the 17th of April, 2023 at 7.30pm. Replay will be available if you can't make it. And the next one after that will be Tuesday, the 2 of May 2023 at 7 30 p.m too please do bear in mind that the clinical psychologist collective book and the aspiring psychologist collective books can be really useful prep for you in terms of thinking about how you are reflective and how you might appropriately share that at interviews so do bear that in mind listen to a quick jingle for one of them now and I'll be back along very shortly I'm the way to get to qualify. So many tips and lessons to learn from.
请花点时间在收听时滚动到YouTube并订阅Dr. Marianne Trent。你可以在那里观看回放，也可以通过我的社交媒体Dr. Marianne Trent参加直播环节。下一次直播是在2023年4月17日星期一晚上7:30。如果你无法参加，会有回放。再下一次是在2023年5月2日星期二晚上7:30。请记住，《临床心理学家集体》和《有抱负的心理学家集体》这两本书在思考如何进行反思以及如何在面试中适当地分享这些反思方面，对你非常有帮助。请记住这一点，现在先听一段其中一本书的短曲，我很快就会回来。通往合格的道路。有太多的技巧和经验可以学习。
So many things that you can try. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective Are you still loving those jingles? I hope so. They're often in my head and I'm singing them. And I even found myself singing the one about Dr. Marianne Trent the other day, which felt slightly narcissistic. So I would love it if you would come and connect with me
有太多的事情你可以尝试。《有抱负的心理学家集体》。《有抱负的心理学家集体》。你还在喜欢这些短曲吗？我希望如此。它们经常在我脑海里回响，我甚至会跟着唱。前几天我甚至发现自己在唱关于Dr. Marianne Trent的那首，这感觉有点自恋。所以我很希望你能来和我联系，
on my socials Dr Marianne Trent everywhere pretty much and keep keep me up to date with how you're doing right now let me know where you're at if you've got any ideas for future podcast episodes that might be useful for the stage of your career that you're at right now then do please get in contact and let me know because I want to make sure that this is really useful for you whatever stage of your journey you're at. Do always remember that there's the free supervision shaping tool that you can access from my website as well,
在我的社交媒体上，基本上到处都是Dr. Marianne Trent。请随时让我了解你的最新进展。如果你对未来的播客节目有什么想法，并且对你目前所处的职业阶段有帮助，请务必联系我并告诉我，因为我想确保这对你来说确实有用，无论你处于旅程的哪个阶段。请永远记住，你也可以从我的网站访问免费的督导塑造工具，
www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash supervision. Thank you so much for watching and listening and being part of my world i will look forward to catching up with you for our next episode which is available from 6 a.m on monday take care if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast. With Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book.
www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/supervision。非常感谢你的观看、收听并成为我世界的一部分。我期待在下一期节目中与你相见，节目将于周一早上6点发布。保重。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这成为你的指南。有这个播客在身边，你将走上成为合格心理学家的道路。这是《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我是Marianne Trent博士。我叫Jana，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。
I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我发现关于不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。成为临床心理学家的途径之多让我感到惊讶，没有完美的途径。这让我充满了信心，意识到我并没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。